foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar thinking
translational things to consider in car
T cell workflows I am Sabrina Lemos of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by miltony biotech to
learn more visit miltonybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation I'd like to now welcome our
speaker Robert Davies cell culture
product manager at miltony biotech
Robert you may now begin your
presentation
hello and welcome to today's webinar
thinking translational things to
consider in car t workflows
I'm Robert Davies cell culture product
manager at miltoni biotech
before starting the presentation please
briefly acknowledge our disclaimer
displayed on this slide here
taking a look at today's agenda we will
first look at the path to cell therapies
from early Discovery to
commercialization and the challenges
that you might face in the different
phases
then I will elaborate on the key points
to consider when pursuing translation
from small to large scale Manufacturing
next I will talk about the many suitable
tools that enable a smooth transition
from small scale research to large-scale
workflows
finally I will end the presentation with
a brief summary and some suggested
resources as a follow-up to this
presentation
let's start off with a question
what is your vision when it comes to car
T Cell Therapy
every one of us will have unique goals
based on development timelines
however
I think we can all agree that our shared
overall vision
is to develop car T cells that work
translate them into the clinic and
successfully treat cancer patients
however as we all know this is a long
process
it starts with basic research and
Discovery and goes into pre-clinical
development clinical studies and
ultimate results in a marketed therapy
that can make a difference to a
patient's life
cell and Gene therapies including car T
cells come with a lot of unique
challenges as a novel therapeutic
approach due to its in increased
complexity as a living cell therapy
similar to other therapies development
challenges differ from phase to phase
in a research setting you need to narrow
down targets develop safe car T cells
and validate them
in the translational phase you need to
transfer your small scale protocol to a
large scale process
eventually you will also need to address
regulatory requirements coordinate with
an increasing number of enrolled
patients and keep an eye on costs
as your challenges change so do your
needs at the discovery phase
you need a high degree of flexibility
and a diverse set of methods whereas
later on high standardization and
process automation will be key
it is obvious that the path to a
marketed car T Cell Therapy is not an
easy one
however success has been proven as
reflected by the increasing number of
commercially available car T Cell
Therapies
as of recently there are six therapies
on the market to treat cd19 and bcma
positive malignancies
and a lot more are in the pipeline
a recent count shows a total of 1
115 clinical car T trials have been
initiated
the number of clinical trials are
expected to continue to increase as
shown by the trend line within the graph
on the right hand side
miltoni biotech has been and continues
to be very active in the field of cell
and gene therapy as such we are familiar
with its unique challenges and have
developed Integrated workflows Solutions
and tools for the development of car T
Cell Therapies
given our experience and expertise in
the car T research and Manufacturing
field let's discuss some considerations
that can help streamline the transition
from small-scale research to large-scale
Manufacturing
when pursuing the path to translation
it helps to plan with the end in mind
consideration towards reagents devices
and methods ahead of time can help avoid
added cost and keep your development
timelines on track
we will use the following workflow
depicted here as a way of illustrating
the steps involved with a generation or
manufacturing of car T cells
first starting with human blood products
followed by T Cell isolation
activation via CD3 cd28 receptor
engagement
Gene delivery the X Vivo expansion
as well as phenotypic and functional
verification
we integrated and developed a broad
range of products that are used in both
research and clinical settings that can
allow for a seamless transition of your
whole research workflow to The clinimax
Prodigy platform
automating an end-to-end closed system
makes manufacturing more scalable robust
and reliable
human error is frequently identified as
one of the highest risk elements of a
manufacturing process leading to
protocol deviations and batch failures
automation mitigates these risks by
providing repeatable and reliable cell
processing
in addition to having a scalable robust
and reliable platform for manufacturing
The clinomax Prodigy platform features a
specialized T-cell transduction process
that is uniquely designed to support the
needs of T-cell manufacturing including
teat car T cells inclusive of all the
critical steps from cell separation to
final product formulation
while we may speak positively about our
own products that support the
development of card T therapies don't
just take our word for it there have
been several peer-reviewed studies
published
in the last several years that can
attest to our success in supporting
T-cell engineering
now let's take a closer look at the
workflow itself and the various
solutions to consider to help transition
the development process to
commercialization
T Cell isolation is the first step we'll
review
in a research setting several methods
are frequently used depending on the
type of starting material and cell
population targeted for isolation
when it comes to translation there are
some considerations including
optimal reproducibility of results
reagents available in GMP quality
isolation methods that can translate to
an automated system
and clinical process that may already
been established or exist
Bill Tenney biotech is well known for
its cell separation technology so I
invite you to browse our website to
learn more about this technology
and always reach out to me to help you
find the resources you need to help
guide the transition of your cell
separation process from research to
clinical applications
the next step after T-cell separation is
reliable Cell Activation to facilitate
one
successful transduction
and two an efficient expansion of the
gene engineered T cells
there are several Solutions available
that can provide Cell Activation as
listed here but there are several
considerations to keep in mind such as
optimal reproducibility of results
for reagents available in GMP quality
activation res agents that are suitable
for automated closed systems
clinical processes that may already have
been established or exist
a proven track record
and safety
given these considerations especially
for translational applications aimed
towards car T-cell needs in both the
research and clinical setting altene
biotech developed an Innovative active
activation reagent called T Cell
transact
T Cell transact activates T cells
classically via CD3 cd28 engagement
however as a polymeric nano Matrix
T-cell transact can be easily dosed
volumetrically
can be removed by simple washing
and is available in a GMP compliant
format
this not only facilitates more robust
T-cell activation but most importantly
eliminates tedious debating
this product is fully compatible with
automated manufacturing platforms such
as The clinomax Prodigy making the
translatability of T-cell activation as
easy as it gets
shown here you can see that 24 hours
after the addition of T Cell transact we
observed typical T Cell cluster
formation indicative of T Cell
Activation
after 48 Hours T Cell Activation was
verified by flow cytometry
as shown activation markers cd25 and
cd69 were found to be upregulated
up to 80 percent of the T-cell
population expressed both markers
now that we've seen the results let's
take a step back and briefly review the
process that leads to successful Cell
Activation using T Cell transact
here the T cells were pelleted and
resuspended at a concentration of 10 to
the six cells per ml in Tex-Mex medium
supplemented with T Cell transact and
il-7 il-15 cytokines for activation
from this cell suspension two Mills were
filled into a 24 well plate
24 hours after seeding the cells were
transduced by adding the appropriate
amount of lentiviral vectors
three days after activation activation
medium was replaced by Tex-Mex medium
supplemented with il-7 il-15 cytokines
the transduced cells were split at least
every third day
or when the cell Confluence exceeded 70
percent
in some cases translatability can be
easier said than done as such we've
developed a resource that directly
compares the performance of research use
and GMP compliant transact using a
method similar to the one shown in the
previous slide
I invite you to read through this
resource to gain a better understanding
of how both research use and GMP
compliant T-cell transact show identical
results with strong reproducibility
I invite you to download this app note
that has recently been published on our
website to learn more about the data
that supports this conclusion in further
detail
there are many solutions on the market
that can support cell expansion
compatible with either serum
supplemented or serum free media
however there are several considerations
to think about when planning ahead for
translation such as
reproducibility of cell cultural results
reagents being available in GNP quality
medium that's available with or without
phenol bed
bottles versus bags
and unit specific dosing
when you eventually transition to
clinical applications using a serum free
workflow is advantageous
for clinical car T Cell manufacturing we
developed Tex-Mex medium to support
serum free GMP compliant and highly
reproducible cell expansion
cytokines manufactured by military
biotech feature lot specific biological
activity to even better ensure
reproducible results regardless of
manual or automated processes
lot specific activity can help avoid
oversaturation to better ensure the
expansion of memory T cells as opposed
to a factor T cells that are not as
ideal for car T's
as depicted here various starting
material healthy donor different
patients Frozen samples
can be used with no effect on cell
counts expansion and viability when
following this workflow
now let's switch gears and discuss cell
Analytics
in both research and clinical settings
there is a need to analyze results with
the most common method being flow
cytometry
as we've done with the previous workflow
steps there are a few considerations to
think about including
reproducibility of flow results
confirmed performance of the design
panel
harmonization of instruments
user dependency of analysis
reports
and protocols
consistent with our ability to address
the needs shared by both researchers and
manufacturers alike our approach to flow
cytometry is centered partly on the aim
towards reducing the variability
affecting cell Analytics
while our Affinity antibodies provide
High lots of lot consistency due to
their unique design their use with our
Max Quant instruments and corresponding
software are all made to create reliable
and reproducible flow Analytics
with the smart gain technology you can
take an instrument setting from one
device to another and Achieve equivalent
performance the idea is to provide
reliable data from test to test user to
user instrument to instrument and across
sites
with Express modes automated gating
adjustments based on algorithms can
avoid variations caused by human
intervention
the gating can be preset making the
analysis automated leaving the user with
time to do other things
as an extension of these capabilities we
support a high degree of automation with
customization options as needed as a
part of our continual application
support
since we are discussing our support for
car T therapy development it's worth
taking some time to talk about our carb
detection reagents
the car detection reagents are primarily
comprised of our re-affinity antibodies
providing reliable lot to lot
consistency and designed to detect
engineered T cells expressing cd19 or
cd20 cars on the cell's surface
the reagents come pre-titrated ready to
use while also featuring a mutated igg-1
FC to reduce background staining
when avoiding the need to manually dose
antibodies and or perform fcr blocking
altogether these features allow for
reduced manual intervention leading to
simplified assays and improved
reproducibility
in addition to the car detection
reagents the alternate biotech offers
several re-affinity stain Express flow
panels that come as dried pre-formulated
antibody cocktails
the stain Express panels are compatible
with the automated Express mode analysis
software to standardize and greatly
reduce Hands-On time when performing
analysis on your resulting car T cells
standardization doesn't necessarily need
to come at the expense of flexibility
as you can see there are several
predefined panels that can support the
various development phases of car T Cell
Therapy from small scale research to
full-scale Manufacturing
now that we're at the home stretch I'll
quickly summarize this presentation and
provide some suggested resources to
review as follow-up
I hope it has become clear by thinking
translational early on is beneficial to
ease the transition from the research
phase to commercial Manufacturing
as we've demonstrated throughout this
presentation the workflow for T-cell
engineering is complex and requires many
specialized Solutions
keeping your development plans on time
when making the transition from research
to clinical application requires
planning ahead to ensure that each step
that was previously manual in a small
scale setting can be supported by
automated easy to use and GMP compliance
solution that are ideal for commercial
Manufacturing for nearly every research
product mentioned in this workflow a
counterpart exists that can support GMP
process
a few things before we end the
presentation
as follow-up to this presentation please
consider reviewing the following
resources by scanning the QR code
provided
we hope that you'll gain a better
understanding on how milteni biotech can
support your car T Cell Therapy
development and other T Cell based
applications
if you have any questions or want to
discuss how military biotech can support
your unique needs
military biotech is present in 23
countries and we have representatives in
a total of 73 countries worldwide
I also invite you to follow us on the
various social media platforms
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram
stay tuned and don't miss our latest
scientific Publications free research
protocols travel Awards and latest
product releases
if you have any specific questions to
this webinar please write us an email
and we will get back to you as soon as
possible thank you for your time and
have a wonderful day
thank you Robert for your informative
presentation we are also joined by
Robert's colleague Lorenz Fula Global
product manager at miltony biotech
we now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask the question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so our first question I have here
for you guys how does the straight form
whole blood technology works
oh yeah that's an interesting question
um just to to reiterate a little bit on
that so straight from is actually rather
simple it works
um just like regular microbeads however
straight from Whole blood microbeads
actually enable a direct magnetic cell
separation from Whole blood various
whole blood products for example
Luca Parks or lrcs or others and you can
enrich various leukocytes subsets CD4
positive cd8 positive T cells monocytes
so C 14 positive T cells also B cells
and you can also do that either manually
I'm using our manual separators or also
automated using our various automated
instruments and what else the best thing
is actually that you don't need to
perform any density gradient
centrifugation
but you can just directly use the
isolated cells for your car T Cell
generation or for flow cytometric
analysis or other
um for example also molecular biological
applications or functional studies also
thank you for that answer the next one I
have what's the difference between
transact and other based simulation
reagents
corrupt do you want or should I
sure I can take that
um so with the with the transact the the
important aspect I think with uh this as
opposed to other debate simulation is
that there is no debating that really
needs to be involved
um it's volumetrically dosed so you
don't actually have to do any math in
terms of cells uh to be ratio uh
volumetrically dose so that is an easy
to use a part of the aspect of the
product uh but it's also not a deed so
it's actually no debating as it is
needed so it actually with a simple
media wash
um upon after activation uh the dilution
out of the transact is all that's needed
it's sufficient for the D to uh remove
transact from your cell culture
um so in the and the other aspect of it
is that it is um a colloidal nanometrix
meaning that there's really no vortexing
involved so you know the the need for
being able to do pre-mixing is re is
greatly reduced so
um all together it comes off as a really
you know really nice easy to use
off-the-shelf product for a T-cell
simulation
yeah just just to add on that I mean
it's also suitable for the cleaning Max
Prodigy right because we have it also in
in Max GMP grade I think that's also
um right that's exactly it and that that
definitely um is a huge support of our
translatability aspect of our car T
workflow and that is you know with the
side clients for expansion uh transact
for Activation as well as our Tex-Mex
T-cell media
um both exist in both RDO and GMP
formats so that those three main pillars
of a T Cell cultivation
um are fully translatable
foreign
looks like we have one more question
here how do I know that the max Quant is
a good fit for both clinical and
research applications
do you want to you want to start Rob
um I think the I think uh just to kind
of start us off with that
um the I think the main aspect is really
the the automation
um that's real that's that's part that's
ingrained within the max Quant
um lends itself you know to both
research and and clinical applications
um so you know if something is
determined to be optimized in a in a
research or even a process development
setting
um that's something that can actually be
carried over quite easily and within the
instruments to a commercial setting that
might be really more applicable or more
important to uh IPC QC uh functionality
just
yeah just to add on that I mean miltoni
has done a great job to really develop
um a whole family of Max Squan flow
cytometers
so I think until now we actually have
four different instruments really
fitting to specific applications so like
like you said whether you're coming from
from research or clinical applications
you can just
um get the instrument that really is
attuned to your your specific
applications or your specific needs be
it high automation
um High parameters or also optimized for
fluorescent protein detection for
example
right exactly and I really think the the
preset panels
um the antibody cocktails
um and the the various uh software uh
capabilities really lend itself to
making it about you know really very
very streamlined very minimal manual
intervention is needed
um and that can be you know a definitely
a benefit for both research and
Commercial applications
oh yeah exactly
nice
um that looks like all the questions
do you have any final comments for our
audience
[Music]
um the other final comment I would have
is
um you know please uh don't be shy in
reaching out to us
um you know for you know to to explore
you know more about our car T solutions
for both research and clinical
um there is more than what there's a lot
more that we offer and can you can learn
about than what we'll be covered in this
presentation
um so there is a you know obviously
within car t uh we are well established
and being able to provide holistic
workflows
um you know starting material to you
know a final finish so uh I would I
would invite anyone that is curious um
that would like to try anything
um or it just wants to be able or would
like to have a talkative sales
representative
um please let us know
um we can definitely start to help help
you guys you know elevate your car team
research and and clinical applications
well said I don't have much to add thank
you very much
yeah I think so too thank you very much
all right thank you so much guys thank
you again Robert and Lorenz for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltony biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have um time for today or those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of your registration and this
webcast can also be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and until next time goodbye